et pour continuer à parler de ses
percées scientifiques notre chroniqueuse
santé nous a rejoint bonjour julia
seeger
outre ces implants de moelle épinière
inde autre type d'implant pour le
cerveau cette fois ci sont développés
dans le but de rendre toute l'autonomie
aux patients qui sont paralysés oui
alors le nom est assez barbare mais il
s'agit en fait d'interface cerveau
machine ça désigne en fait un système de
liaison directe entre le cerveau du
patient et un ordinateur au travers de
l'implantation effectivement d'une puce
dans le cerveau et donc un ça va
permettre à un individu par exemple
d'effectuer différentes tâches sans
passer par l'action des nerfs
périphériques ou encore des muscles si
je doit simplifier ça veut dire que par
l'action grâce à cette a7 micro puce
grâce à à la puissance de la pensée on
va pouvoir justement agir sur un
ordinateur et pourquoi pas après sur une
prothèse ou sur un autre type de système
comme on va le voir dans un instant
comme par exemple sur un exosquelette
sans même sollicité les bras les jambes
ou encore les mains et c'est un concept
qui remonte en fait à 1973 les premiers
essais cliniques sur l'homme ont
commencé dans les années 90 et c'est
vrai que depuis il ya eu de grandes
avancées scientifiques et peut-être le
projet le plus fou qu'on a actuellement
c'est celui dillon masque qui s'appelle
ne ralink alors ils ont effectivement
fait une démonstration notamment avec un
singe un macaque de 9 ans qui s'appelle
la page airs que vous allez voir ici et
en fait donc il a un implant de puces
dans son cerveau et il est en train de
jouer au jeu de pong
par la force de sa pensée donc au début
ils étaient reliés au système est là on
l'a on l'a retiré du système est tout
simplement en réfléchissant il est en
train de faire bouger justement le jeu
donc c'est assez incroyable et donc à
terme ce que ça veut dire c'est que ça
va permettre aux personnes paralysées
par exemple de pouvoir à distance gérer
un exosquelette alors on sait évidemment
certains vont trouver que ses fans ici
dans d'autres vont trouver que c'est
terrifiant parce que derrière tout ça et
bien c'est l'homme augmenté bien sûr et
c'est l'interface humains machine ou
vraiment en fait on devient presque
bionique on sait que le but c'est
justement d'aller vers ça à terme en
tout cas le but dillon masque
il explique d'ailleurs dans un de ses
tweets que ça va permettre par exemple
aux gens notamment paralysé parce que
dans un premier temps il le présente
comme une avancée scientifique pour la
médecine mais sa valeur permet par
exemple d'envoyer des textos extrêmement
rapidement puisque vous n'utilisez même
plus vos mains vous êtes en train de
penser le texto en tout cas pour
l'instant ce qui l'a annoncé il ya
seulement quelques jours c'est que il va
en 2022 commencer les essais cliniques
sur l'homme après avoir fait ses essais
cliniques notamment sur les macaques
mais aussi sur un cochon vous l'avez
évoqué julia les exosquelettes ont
vraiment évolué de manière
exceptionnelle absolument les
exosquelettes sont vraiment
exceptionnelles aujourd'hui incroyable
il a d'énormément de personnes notamment
qui souffrent de lésions de la moelle
épinière ou encore qui ont subi un
accident vasculaire cérébral ou qui ont
des troubles neurologiques ce sont des
systèmes aujourd'hui qui sont bionique
très léger qui sont anatomique et et
c'est vraiment une grande prouesse au
niveau robotique clairement mais une
fois de plus le problème c'est que ce
n'est pas connectée au cerveau donc il
ya un manque d'autonomie vous l'avez vu
dans le reportage tout à l'heure il y a
un implant dans la moelle épinière mais
quelqu'un doit bien gérer les actions
avec une tablette à distance et le
problème en fait de ces micro un plan
comme par exemple celui de noeux ralink
sais que c'est très invasif on le met
dans le cerveau et qui a des grands
risques d'infection également et après
qu'est ce qu'on fait la situation peut
devenir extrêmement compliqué c'est pour
ça que d'autres scientifiques cherchent
encore d'autres solutions notamment des
scientifiques de l'université de
grenoble chehat clinatec ils ont créé un
système cette fois ci sur le crâne qui
est semi invasive donc pas complètement
dans le crâne et la personne doit
s'entraîner notamment avec ce système
pour ensuite pouvoir utiliser sa pensée
encore une fois pour faire des actions
merci beaucoup jules à 6 heures pour
cette chronique sens